all right thank you very much bill we
are following very closely the uh
governor of california gavin newsom he
is outlining the uh
really the strictest provisions uh since
the height of the pandemic back in march
and april because of a serious spike
in cases governor newsom among other
things is looking at stay-at-home orders
and trying to make this as voluntary as
possible
but hinting that if people do not
cooperate there could be problems
he's dividing the state into at least
five regions and lockdowns would last
for
minimum of three weeks which will take
us right to the cusp of the holiday
season so what happens right now
we're over the fallout also going to be
getting reaction very shortly
from the governor of ohio who has put
his own state on a
well a no travel list if you will in the
meantime william lodge and us in los
angeles with the latest from the golden
state
and how far this crackdown goes hey
william
well neil as you said this is being
driven by hospital and icu bed capacity
and basically what the governor said as
you said stays being broken into five
regions
and as each region hits a 85 percent
capacity in their uh reaching their
limitation if you will 85 percent of the
beds being full in the icu
that will trigger if you will these new
restrictions
and basically what it means is obviously
restaurants indoor outdoor
closed hair salons massage parlors
closed schools
can be reopened on a partial basis
there'll be a little wiggle room there
for them
also you can walk and you can bike with
your partner but no large gatherings
at all and basically the governor is
saying hey this is a
intent obviously to get a control on
this now santa clara county and parts of
northern california are supposed to hit
that threshold
probably today or tomorrow the other
regions are saying
by probably mid-december also i meant to
say that retail would be limited to 20
of capacity so if you have a small
boutique that could be two people
if it's a big box store this can be
something else but we remember what that
was like back in uh uh march and april
if you will
um the governor says that's going to be
at least until new year's day
and he believes that those mitigations
if you will
will help reduce the the caseload and
the
stress on the hospital system they are
opening two facilities arco arena near
sacramento
and also imperial valley college uh out
near el centro which has had a
surge of patients there and there are
over capacity there in the icu beds
already
in that area and there are nine other
facilities that will open
with 100 to 200 beds as required neil
william thank you very much my friend we
elijah nasa california where they're
really cracking down
we're